JENNY BROWN: And we're back.
Today we're talking about
the new Cloud Operations
Sandbox, data security
strategies, and a new AppSheet
tutorial.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud Operations Sandbox
is an open source tool
that helps you learn SRE
practices from Google,
and then apply them on Cloud
Services using Google Cloud's
operations suite.
It's got everything you need to
get started in just one click.
So be sure to check out the
blog post for more information.
Our new whitepaper
explores the questions
of building a data security
program in a Cloud-native way,
and of adapting an
existing program to utilize
Cloud computing services.
Read the blog post for more
best practices and background
information, or download the
paper to learn for yourself.
AppSheet is Google Cloud's
no-code app development
platform.
And this tutorial
walks you through it
by building a
usable fitness app.
And more importantly,
it provides you
the skills to
build any app you'd
like without needing to code.
A new year is a great chance
to learn something new.
And I recently had
the opportunity
to learn directly from Cassie
Kozyrkov, our head of Decision
Intelligence.
Check out the
podcast to hear more
about the role of
decision-makers,
your intuition, and
data in decision-making.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.